they already know what real numbers are
these are the numbers that can be
represented on the number line we also
know that real numbers can be broadly
classified as rational and irrational
numbers rational numbers are those that
can be represented as ratio of two
integers with no common factor
irrational numbers on the other hat
cannot be expressed as ratio of two
integers and when expressed in decimal
notation they are non terminating
non-recurring decimals are there any
other kinds of numbers numbers that we
haven't looked at yet before you answer
that question let me ask you another one
can you think of a number which when
squared results in a negative number yes
a number which when multiplied with
itself gives a negative number try it
you'd have probably tried a few options
3 times 3 is 9
positive negative 5 times negative 5 is
25 again positive negative root 3 times
negative root 3 is 3 positive again no
luck we'll come back to this don't worry
so we studied quadratic equations in
middle school we know that if x squared
minus 9 is equal to 0 X is either equal
to 3 or negative 3 now try to find a
solution
2x squared plus 1 equal to 0 not sure or
do you think there's no solution to this
one don't worry if you couldn't get the
answer to these two questions let's
understand the situation now whenever we
consider the square of a number say X
the result was always positive whether
the number X was a positive real number
or a negative 1 we always got a positive
result and we had learned that a
negative number did not have a square
root so if we had a number like negative
9 we said that it's square root did not
exist do you remember that while finding
the solution of a quadratic equation
using the formula
if the discriminant b squared minus 4ac
was negative we said that there are no
real roots of the quadratic equation
based on what we had studied earlier x
squared plus 1 equal to 0 will not have
any real roots as the value of
discriminant is negative 4 why did we do
this what was the problem here it's easy
as the square root of negative 1 did not
exist for us we said that there was no
solution for the equation x squared plus
1 equals 0
however in the 16th century it was a
mathematician named Cardin who first
started thinking about solutions of
quadratic equations with negative
discriminants soon others started to but
it was Euler in the 18th century who
gave the square root of negative 1 a
symbol I and called it the unit
imaginary number
these were terms so as they were thought
to be impossible and just something we
imagined so I was assumed to be a number
whose square is negative 1 now you'll be
able to answer the two questions can you
think of a number which when squared
results in a negative number
yes it's I if square root of negative 1
is I what is I times I or I squared it
is root negative 1 times root negative 1
that gives us negative 1 there you go
we cut a negative number by squaring a
number and the next question was can you
find a solution 2x squared plus 1 equal
to 0 the answer is yes transposing one
to the right-hand side we get x squared
as negative 1 taking the square root on
both sides we get the value of x as root
of negative 1 or minus root of negative
1 that is plus minus I so what we learnt
in school wasn't incorrect this equation
has no real roots yes it has imaginary
roots that's the concept of imaginary
numbers for you but wait
we understood the concept of square root
of negative one what if the number is
square root of negative seven or square
root of negative nine
that's what we will cover in the next
video
[Music]
you